all right we are now live
once again for another uh political
theory
and practice discussion um this time
we're going to be centering again
on some issue in american politics
that's kind of a hot button issue
and it's prompted by the recent town
hall meeting that
joel biden had here in milwaukee
actually just blocks from from here
where we live and i thought it could be
an interesting topic to dig into you
know
it's something that i think we have to
do a little bit of explanation for
non-american viewers so let me do that
first when we're talking about
student loans these are loans that
people take out for post-secondary
education so that could be
graduate school that could be
undergraduate that could be
at a two-year college earning an
associate degree
that can be for professional schools
like
law school medical school you know all
of those are included in it
technical schools would be included as a
matter of fact some of our institutions
of higher learning
as i was doing some of the research for
this are hair cutting
and and makeup schools you know um
all of that falls under that and i think
that
or quite a few people you know in in
some countries where education
uh particularly college is difficult to
get into but not very expensive
once you actually do get in and may even
be covered by
um you know you may have even like your
your
your costs of living covered to some
degree the american situation is
very very very different so
here we don't have an educational system
you could say in higher ed
instead what we have is a whole bunch of
different
institutions which are regulated in
different ways
they're not all on the same page they we
we can make some comparisons like we can
say well what is tuition at least right
but the cost of tuition as we're going
to talk about in just a bit
very wildly you know tuition could be as
low
as um seven thousand dollars in some
places
all the way up to seventy thousand
dollars and then there's room and board
and the cost of books and all these
other things and there's no like you
know federal regulation of this
it's all up to the institutions and if
it's a state school it's up to the state
in certain ways but there's a lot of
local control
so i think that's one of the things that
you have to keep in mind is we're not
talking about
one vast system we're talking about a
whole bunch of institutions
that form something like a
system but it's very
diverse so there's that that thing right
there
another thing is that for americans
for a number of generations going to
college
has been sold as the way that you move
yourself
up so you know you're going to notice
that there's a reference to like the
american dream
going on the american dream is of having
like a decent job that pays you
enough money so that you can eventually
have a house and you know maybe a couple
cars and go on vacations and
send your kids to college all those
sorts of things
and so people who are taking on
student debt in order to to do
that um that's part of the picture you
know
taking on debt has been posed
really since the time of the baby
boomers in mind and especially my
generation
of generation x is like a good deal and
i think for millennials and generation z
they're saying it's actually not such
such a good deal so we're going to talk
about
that in a bit as well the other thing i
do want to point out
for our foreign attendees is that
student loan debt in america
because of the way federal legislation
has has
opened things up it's really put people
in difficult situations
it's very difficult to get rid of your
student loan debt
um compared to other kinds of debt and
the
the numbers are pretty high we you know
it's estimated that there's about 1.5
trillion dollars right now out there in
student loan debt
you know by comparison to 2004 and this
is coming from the brookings
institution at the brookings institute
that was 250 billion so you know from
15 years or 17 years we have
really increased the the amount of debt
much of it is is held by by people who
want to undergraduate it's not so much
from people who went to elite
institutions as such and we're going to
talk about biden's
kind of wonky views on that in a minute
so here's a few other stats right
student loans are the second largest
slice of household debt after mortgages
bigger than credit card debt about 42
million
americans have student loans so that's
one in eight
about 75 percent of student loan
borrowers went to
two or four-year colleges they account
for half
of the student loan debt the other 25
went to graduate school and they account
for the other half
now when they're saying graduate school
they also mean law school medical school
you know other professional schools
getting an mba things like that so
you know this is this is i think
important information
about 80 of the borrowers that have
student debt according to federal data
have student debt under 50 000 but it
can be you know quite a bit
and so you know what are the proposals
been the numbers that get thrown around
right now
are cancelling out fifty thousand
dollars of debt
or ten thousand dollars of debt so we
can associate these with you know for
example
uh warren elizabeth warren uh
she wants fifty thousand dollars of loan
forgiveness
that's been a popular figure thrown
around joe biden uh
president at the latest town hall said
we're not gonna do that
uh it's gonna be ten thousand dollars
which is still you know a good bit a
bit of money so we're going to talk
about some of these things
in a bit before we jump into
his his talk i just want to give you an
idea about how much college costs
and we'll come back to this in a minute
so i i went and looked up you know what
the stats were
on a number of different places so
where i went to college lakeland college
now lakeland university
tuition now is 29 000 a year
and they estimate that books should cost
you about
you know eleven hundred dollars and room
and board
if you stay on campus would be an
additional nine thousand six hundred and
twenty four so you put all that together
and you've got 40 grand a year 40 grand
a year to go to the place that i went to
where i went to graduate school southern
illinois
university carbondale which is a state
school of the illinois system
now in state schools they charge
different rates depending on whether
you're a state resident or whether
you're
from somewhere else so if you're if
you're a resident
fourteen thousand seven hundred dollars
to go to southern illinois university
if you're not a resident it's double
that 28 000
928 906 right they also quote this
1100 thing for books room and board
there is
is 10 000 a year so to go to a state
school
at the cheapest rate 25 000 for
going to southern illinois university
if you look at our state schools here in
wisconsin if you go to uw
madison which is our big flagship school
tuition is ten thousand dollars if
you're in state thirty seven
thousand dollars if you're out of state
if you go to
university of wisconsin milwaukee where
my daughter goes to
uh nine 9500 for tuition if you're in
state
21 000 if you're out of state so it's
you know
it's it's still pretty expensive and
room and board
um we're talking about you know over ten
thousand dollars for either of those
schools
so that means that to go to the place
where my my daughter's going
she's you know the room and board is
actually more than tuition
for that by their own estimates um you
go further
south to chicago if you went to
university of illinois
at chicago 15 grand for tuition if
you're in state 30 grand if you're out
of state
room and board is 12
500. now let's do a little bit of
comparison what if you go to a private
school
so the only thing that we have that's
like ivy league
here in the midwest the central midwest
would be university of chicago that is
60 000 tuition just tuition
room and board seventeen thousand
dollars right
now if you're going to a place out east
it's probably going to be more expensive
or in california
university of notre dame which would
like to pretend that it's it's ivy
league but definitely isn't
uh 55 000 a year for tuition
uh 15 000 for room and board so that's
70 grand
not even counting books get a couple
other ones just to give you some
comparison
marquette university just down the road
from us
not a ivy league school private school
decent you know
private school 43 000 a year for tuition
13 000 for room and board and then they
estimate 816 dollars for
for books and their their rival loyola
in chicago is about the same a little
bit more expensive
um cardinal strich which would be
another catholic college smaller here
in wisconsin in the milwaukee area 31
thousand dollars a year
for tuition 8950. so that gives you an
idea about
what some of these college costs are
that's here in the midwest
like i said if you're you know if you're
out east
it's going to cost you more if you're in
california it's going to cost you more
that's not including fees and other
sorts of things like that as well so
this helps people to have some sort of
sense of what we're
talking about in the money stuff
no name whatsoever said those figures
sound like taken from a dystopian
science fiction novel
they might to outsiders these are the
sort of things that that you find out
here in the united states these are
like normal figures these are what
college tends to cost you
so there was this town hall meeting
right
and jocelyn fish said the american dream
is to succeed
how can we fulfill that dream when debt
is many people's only
option for a degree we need student loan
forgiveness beyond the potential ten
thousand dollars your administration has
proposed
we need at least a fifty thousand dollar
minimum
what will you do to make it happen and
now i'm going to say something here
i actually like uh uh biden's response
in part because he starts off by saying
i will not make that happen we were
watching it at the time
and i was like holy crap you know that's
nice a politician who just like
doesn't [ __ ] around about this and
then he gave a long explanation that i
think is
you know it's on point in certain ways
it's problematic
in other ways so he said i'm not going
to make that happen it depends on
whether or not you go to a private
university or a public university
it depends on the idea that i say to a
community i'm going to forgive the debt
the billions of dollars of debt for
people who've gone to harvard and yale
and penn
and schools my children i went to a
great school i went to a state school
but is that going to be forgiven rather
than use that money to provide for early
education for young children who come
from disadvantaged circumstances
that's a red herring right there but
we'll talk about that in a minute
so he says here's what i think i think
everyone and i've been proposing this
for years
everyone should be able to go to
community college for free
that costs 9 billion and we should pay
for it
so that's that's a good idea we'll come
back to that
i think any family making under 125 000
whose kids go to a state university they
get into that should be free as well
and the thing i do in terms of student
debts that's accumulated
is provide for changing the existing
system now for debt forgiveness if you
engage in volunteer activity
so for example if you're teaching school
after five years you'd have fifty
thousand dollars of your debt forgiven
so it sounds like ten thousand dollars
for each year that you're doing public
service
of some sort if you worked in a battered
woman's shelter
he says i'm also going to change the
position we have now to allow for debt
forgiveness because it's so hard to
calculate whereby you can now depending
on how much you make
and what program you it you can work
that debt by the activity you have
and not be charged more than than x
percent of your take-home pay
so it doesn't affect your ability to buy
a car own a home etc
so you know those are all interesting
ideas
i think a lot of those are are quite
good
then he brings up his example of his
kids and here's where we come to one of
the key
ideas you know the country here should
not be between
private ivy league and public state
universities because the ivy league is
just a tiny sliver
admittedly they're the ones who have the
best endowments
and tend to vote the best job have the
best network and stuff like that but
most schools are not ivy league if you
go to cardinal stritch
that's not an ivy league school
marquette here in milwaukee loyola
in in chicago those are not ivy league
as i mentioned university of notre dame
they'd like to pretend their ivy league
but they ain't ivy league
so you know the the contrast should be
much more variegated it should not just
be state schools
versus ivy league which we should
actually look at different state schools
too
some some state schools can be very
expensive
especially if you're you know not a
resident other state schools where
it's much more supported and they don't
have to jack the tuition rates up so
high
much cheaper right so these are some
really
important considerations when we're
going to talk about this
we have to you know be careful not to
just like pretend that the ivy league is
where most of these students
who have acquired more than 50 000 in
debt are are actually going
they're going to places like marquette
they're going to places like milwaukee
institute of art and design where i
teach
you know where just to give you a
comparison um
what is the uh tuition there
it is 38
500 a year and room and board
is 9 300. um
and that doesn't include i mean they say
750 for books
but you know you also have to buy all
these art supplies and stuff like that
so you know there are quite a few
students who are taking out loans
in order to finance this and they're not
necessarily going to
the ivy leagues as biden is um
presenting it so i think that's that's a
a good you know criticism of his his
position on that
but i would say you know looking at some
of these things
um should community college be made free
there's a good argument for that uh now
a lot of people don't want to go to
community colleges
because of you know it's it's it's not
as good and all that
i can tell you as somebody who's worked
in community colleges and has a lot of
peers in them and has worked in a number
of other institutions
the quality of education is not really
vary you're not going to get a better
education necessarily at marquette
taking
intro to philosophy class as you are at
milwaukee area technical college because
guess what i teach at both and i look at
some of my peers and i can tell that
the quality is not radically different
and the same thing with people from ivy
league institutions if you go to
harvard because you think the education
is going to be radically better
you will find out that that's not the
case
what's better is the name and their
connections
and the alumni network if you can make
that work for you
so that's you know the idea of sending
people to community colleges is not a
bad
idea many of my friends and peers their
kids will go to community college for
the first two years get a bunch of the
credits in
and then go to another school i've
taught a lot of students like that they
weren't any
less prepared than students in other
places
the idea of making state university free
for
any family under 120 making under 125
000
um that's an interesting proposal it
probably needs to be indexed to cost a
living because
you know making 125 000 a year
here in the milwaukee area is pretty
good
uh making that in the middle of new york
city
that's uh you know that's not gonna go
quite so far
making that way out in the sticks you're
living pretty high on the hog then
so we probably in order to make things
more more equitable need to
you know even that out a bit but that
seems like a
pretty reasonable position the idea
so when biden proposed you know by doing
service you could you could shave off
another 10 grand of your loans each year
there was a lot of backlash against that
they called that indentured servitude
and all that
these ideas have been around for a while
i mean americorps was doing doing that
back in the clinton era so it's not a
radically
new way of doing things
um and is it indentured servitude
i mean i don't think so i think that's
really a huge stretch to say that
i can see how people would be like well
that reduces my capacity to
move around but it's not like the job
market is great anyway
so i don't really buy that argument and
i really do like this idea that he has
i'd like to see if you can pull this off
that you wouldn't be able to be charged
more than some percent of your take-home
pay
so that it wouldn't uh have the effect
that it has
on student loan debt on so many people
so all right so there's a lot of
questions and comments let's uh
take a look at some of these um
so gutter grown has a serious issue and
this was a serious issue back
in my time graduating in the 1990s
my girlfriend owes 50 000 for a ba she's
a 4.0 student who can't get a job that
pays more than 15
an hour for her degree yeah there were
people
in generation x who had 50 000 of debt
coming out of
my college and found out that they
couldn't make
uh they couldn't find jobs that were
commensurate to their abilities
having a four panel is nice uh that
doesn't i don't really think that's
that's
relevant to this because all that means
is that
they're able to do the things in in the
classes i don't really care what
somebody's grade point average is if i'm
hiring them
um but you know it this is a broader
issue of
there aren't a lot of jobs out there and
college students have been promised that
if you get that college degree
you're going to find a good job and so
much of it here in the united states
is class dependent right
race also plays a role but but that
often ties in with with class
you know if you come from the upper to
middle classes you've got connections
and they can find you a job you know and
you're not going to have so much
difficulty
it's like all these things where you see
somebody who's like i found a way to
live on fifty thousand dollars a year
and sock away
all this stuff and it turns out that
they were like independently wealthy to
begin with well
if you have wealth that opens all these
doors if you're from you know
lower class to middle class families
and you don't have a academic background
already
so you don't know exactly how to pull
strings and what to do
you may get out and find out that you've
been you know suckered
that um you know there's this contract
that we seem to have
just just get the degree it doesn't
matter what you get it in
but don't get it of course in art
history or anything like that just get a
degree
and your earnings will go up that's not
really the case
and i think a lot of people are becoming
aware of that and so that that's a real
issue thomas has been in debt since
2011.
yeah that's it takes a long time to er
to
work off student loan debt once i
finished graduate school i had to start
paying on and it took me 10 years to pay
off my student loans and my student
loans were relatively
small because when i was at lakeland
college
i had everything covered for tuition and
i just paid room and board
and took out loans for that and when i
was
uh in graduate school for fortunately i
i
got you know fellowships or
assistantships like you know ta
and i was a research assistant but i i
also was lucky that i had very high
scores so
and you know the federal government was
giving more in terms of
like pell grants at that time
all right um michael says
come on you know the 10k is going to get
whittled down to an apple piece gift
card
i doubt that i think there's going to be
some
some student loan forgiveness
and if it is even if it is ten thousand
dollars that will make a significant
difference to people who have loans
given that the majority of people who
have loans they're under
fi they're under fifty thousand dollars
you know some people that may be their
entire loan
um if it halves your loan or you know at
least shaves off a third or a quarter of
it that's
that's something i i think that it will
make it through
um there's a variety of ways in which
the biden administration can make that
happen so that that's good well you know
there's a lot of debate about whether it
should happen we'll get into that in a
bit
all right i'm going to skip isaiah
holland's thing about hegelian
philosophy because it's not relevant
here
skip hoffenflaven it's the only debt i
have and
most likely will die with was it worth
it looking back as well as looking at
how well-rounded my knowledge base is
the ability i have of not being in the
dark when it comes to anything now i
come across while reading watching a
movie following news
the ability to literally learn anything
i did not major in
well an undergraduate graduate from a
major foundation to start with all of
this makes it worth it
plus i have a solid job and career
that's good i mean if student loan debt
is your only debt that's that's awesome
i've had all sorts of debts in my life
you know credit card debt
car payments um you know i haven't had a
mortgage because i actually when
my mom died i used what we had as an
inheritance to buy a house that was
my family owned and uh that was that was
nice to have for a little while
um but you know
it it can be a good um so i mean part of
what what skip is saying
it can be a good bargain if you get a
good education
right um that's another thing we could
talk about quite a bit for a while
there's so much unreliability
going from when you look at things from
the outside what your education is going
to be like
going to any school i mean they all have
the same brochures with the same sort of
univ
you know benetton you know everybody of
every different
race and color nationality all smiling
you know on the beautiful campus
that doesn't tell you anything about
what what the campus is actually like
particularly if you are
uh you know somebody who's in a minority
it doesn't tell you i mean you can look
up you know reports but it doesn't tell
you anything like what the
rate of actual sexual harassment or
abuse is on campus
you can look at the professor's profiles
but you don't know whether they're jerks
or not
whether they'll meet with you in office
hours or or not
it's it's kind of a gamble and and a lot
of times
universities are like a black box you
don't know what you're getting into
until you get into it
all right um xenovalea i think if you
want to be a lawyer doctor write
philosophy then you need to go to
college but if it's something like the
arts then you can self learn
well i would disagree i would say that
milwaukee institute of art and design
which by the way has a
really great placement rate for their
graduates in terms of getting
your remunerative work afterwards
there's a lot of things that you would
learn at a place like that that you
wouldn't just doing things
on your own and you know there are there
are
self-taught people but you usually find
out that the story's not quite so simple
as that
so yeah let's see
dammit says most american youtubers i
watch that are still in uni
talk about their debt as if it's a fact
of life that's
that's an interesting observation yeah i
think that that is correct
um and that also has to do with
how things are being uh sort of
portrayed
within not the media so much but
by like high school counselors or
other other you know cultural um
influencers
where yeah you just you just take on
that debt it's going to be good for you
to do it
i i hated taking loans myself because
i'm a person who
never wanted to be in debt ever um
but you know i found that that i i
needed to
um and i think a lot of other people are
in that that situation as well
so all right
uh let's see here a lot of people
expressing
this is from when i was reading off the
stats about how much college cost
there was a lot of incredulity like is
that really the cost for a year
uh i thought it was for the whole thing
yeah it's it's expensive
um even the places that are that you
know like so biden's saying okay state
school ought to be cheap
it ought to be but the the unfortunate
reality
is that um states largely under the
influence of republican legislatures
over years and years and years have
taken away what used to be really robust
state support for institutions of higher
education within their state
and made them much more tuition
dependent so they have to keep raising
tuition every year
um all right let's see here
oh it just skipped a little bit um
an ordered whole says art schools are
crazy expensive
yeah i mean if you go to the art
institute of chicago it'd be way more
than what maya
is and you know um
there's actually been quite a few of
them that have folded in recent years
too
no name says i was born in the
ex-communist bloc where higher education
is completely free and the perspective
is reversed people find unacceptable the
thought of going into debt for paying
university fees
yeah i mean i think that's it's that way
in many places
um we've gotten ourselves into a weird
situation here in america and i would
say britain
you know is in a similar situation as
well
as as is canada although not as bad
necessarily
as the us where this has become
normalized
that that people should take out these
these massive loans because tuition
should be so expensive
we can also talk about why tuition
became so incredibly
expensive as well and that's a whole
different conversation that has to do
with
bad decision-making and bad priorities
on the part of
educational institutions as well
um mr argentino says in argentina we
don't usually buy full books we pay for
copies of them or now we have them
digitalized
people do that here as well i actually
in my classes that i'm teaching
um if it's in the public domain i i
get it and make a copy of it pdf it and
um you know provide that to students
there's no reason why we have to read
the latest translation
of plato when there's so many good
public domain translations out there
that i could give them in pdf form but a
lot of people
don't do that i've seen you know peers
who had prescribed
10 books you know totaling 300
for their class and you're like what is
wrong with you why would you
you're not even actually going to read
all 10 of these why would you make your
students buy all this stuff
and you know usually those those are the
people whose
parents were professors you know um
all right there's some back and forth
stuff about whether you could be a
lawyer
or not um there's some other irrelevant
stuff about general semantics
i'm going to skip over that
so nine here here's a prevalent
misunderstanding
everything taught in universities can be
studied for free via the internet
universities only provide network and
ease of study structure so that's false
it's not totally false as a matter of
fact it's largely true
but this notion that you can get just as
good an education
as an independent learner doing you know
watching youtube videos
that i'm sorry but that's not the case
and i say that as somebody who produces
youtube videos and uses them for my
my own students and people watch them
there is something with the interaction
with
a professor you know and being within a
structure of things
you know that you're not going to have
there are many people who can learn
things
independently on their own i am one of
those people you know i've i've probably
the stuff that i studied as an
undergraduate and a graduate is probably
maybe uh a fourth of what i've
managed to learn but the the notion that
anybody
can just like get online and do that
this is also by the way what leads to
the
the sort of bs stuff of people are like
why am i paying full
university tuition for online classes
that makes sex that makes sense if your
online classes suck
but when you have instructors who are
investing so much time and energy into
doing online classes well
no i don't i don't think so so um
let's see here just skipped a little bit
victor says i think there's too much
focus on college education in the usa
in germany we have an education system
centered on vocational training this
would open more opportunities
we have that here too it's just not
stressed as much and we have it in a
number of different ways
some states like you know new york have
the boces system
which is similar to the you know the
german tech school uh system you
actually
like in high school you go to a boces
high school
rather than going to a regular one or a
college prep one
and um there's there's others
as well you know that have technical
college things
like that um there's programs that you
can do
in your high school depending on what
your high school is like i mean
obviously we have a big problem with
with underfunded high schools as well
and middle schools and
elementary schools but it's not it's not
like the german system is radically
different than
than what you find in some of the us
system the big difference
it often tends to be that
doing vocational training is looked on
by many people as not a good option for
them
because of the prestige thing there's a
big difference right
going and getting a college degree even
if it's in an easy major
is viewed as like oh you're you're
really attaining something and you know
one of the saddest things that i saw
when i was working with first generation
college students
at a place like fayetteville state
university where there's a lot of
intergenerational poverty among the
students
is there were quite a few students who
thought that they'd made it just by
getting into college and then they
didn't apply themselves
they took out loans then they'd drop out
and now they've got this
this you know debt that's not doing them
any good
so yeah uh let's see here zeno has a
thing that's a little bit on point
um i've been told no one will read your
academic work in philosophy unless you
have a background or an education and
philosophy is this true
no that's that's that's not true uh it
may be that nobody will read your stuff
no matter what
whether you had a degree or not um
there's lots of unread
stuff and you know
you can you can certainly do academic
work and you send it
as an independent scholar or whatever
you want
it's whether it meets the standards of
like peer review which are
totally you know a different topic and i
can tell you
somebody who's been on both sides of
that you know
when you watch the proverbial sausage
being made it'll make you a little bit
bit sick you know i don't think it's
really that important to do
academic work in philosophy
i'm not sure why that that would be an
important
standard there's so much work being
churned out why
add more books to it you know um
all right
so yeah skip says the lack of budget
from states usually red states
hurts higher ed so much missouri is a
great example of this
even in in purple states like wisconsin
so the walker administration did
incredible damage to our uw system
and the republican legislators have done
incredible damage to it
in part because of this perception that
like the universities against them and
all that which
you know i mean in some respects like
like you know stephen colbert
uh observed there is it seems like
reality has a liberal bias
um that's probably kind of true when it
comes to
universities um but a lot of it is is
just about
you know sort of like i don't know i'd
call it like class envy
you know why should i be paying for
somebody else's kids well why the hell
should we pay for the roads you drive on
why should we pay for you know
overpriced defense stuff that we've got
spread out all over the world you can
always ask those
sort of questions politics is about
achieving common goods and
education should be one of those common
goods
um nolan i find it so interesting to see
how much money you can save just by
getting
older editions of books or not getting a
textbook
i did that all the time i'd go get my
books from the library you know
um i i didn't i didn't buy textbooks
a lot of the time or i'd get them at
used bookstores
um oh there's a really great observation
from dukeduke i think we're already
seeing long-term ramifications from the
lack of federal and state support for
education
in the form of constant widespread
misinformation or fake news
so that that's another big topic there's
there's nothing about going to
university that's going to make you
less susceptible to that given a lot of
the stuff that gets taught
you know um and the fact that we often
don't you know we'll have like a
critical thinking class or something
like fayetteville state university had a
critical thinking class
that you could take any time during your
studies and i taught you know like four
sections of the
semester and that was all they were
getting it wasn't coming through the
rest of the curriculum even though
people love to talk about critical
thinking
um but you know getting called on
on silly [ __ ] not being part of you
know the same echo chambers could be
useful i guess
um all right
let's see here vlad says why can some
people self-study and others not
very complex topic you have to get into
like looking at people's individual
ways of learning and their what their
background is and all that
what is it they get from the interaction
with instructor peers again
huge topic all sorts of things
it's not something that there's like one
one answer for
you know so
uh dukduk says one of the biggest
problems with being an autodidact is you
may completely miss what have been
considered essential cornerstones
in any area of study yeah i mean this
can happen also being in a university
like so let's say take philosophy as an
example you go to some place
and they think analytic philosophy and
by that they mean basically post-wine
analytic philosophy
because they don't read their rustle or
more or wisdom or anything like that
that's the only game in town when
everything else is garbage
well if you go to a place like that and
you bring up well
i heard about this dairy dog guy is
there anything there they're going to
discourage you from reading them
and if you're kind of uh you know a lot
of people won't
it's kind of surprising to me but a lot
of people take their professors
recommendations not just of who to read
but who not to read and they follow them
and then you know you talk to them 10
years later and
and they're working on something and
you're like yeah derrida did that
um back in this this work here they're
like gary who and you're like you never
heard of them
oh yeah i think i remember my professors
didn't like them and you're like
well dummy who told you you couldn't
read that stuff even if your professors
don't like it
you can read anything you like because
it's a free country right
and when you go on and on and on you
know people do this with continental
philosophy
they only read like post heidegger on
and they don't know
you know they don't know the people
heidegger is actually referring to
like you know when he references say
bergstone or mock shaler they don't they
don't read that stuff so
it's not a uniquely auto didact problem
um you can run into that and other
things as well
but yeah all right um
let's see here oh
david says what about the argument
pushed by right wingers that debt was
started by leftists and because people
couldn't pay the tuition ended up rising
is that a good argument no it's not even
an argument it's
it's an explanation and it's kind of a
[ __ ] one
what's happened is complex so anybody
who says oh it was just this this this
they're full of crap right and you
shouldn't trust them
this is a complex problem there should
be a complex explanation
and so we have to we have to look for
for those right
um for sure have you ever
ever evaluated graduate school
applications or decided who gets
admitted
no i haven't
um this is not something that that i
would actually even want to do
quite frankly um
joseph now here's here's a good question
does the fact and this might go to the
right wing thing
uh although it's not just the right wing
who's noted this does the fact that
universities know students will be able
to get loans de-incentivize them from
keeping tuition prices low
so yes that that's part of it if if you
know that there's there's money out
there
by the way most of the money is not
being lent by the government it's being
lent by lenders right
so it's not just a a government thing um
that that has been a
a um a factor as i mentioned before the
reason why tuition prices have gone up
is got a different story to it where is
the money actually going to
insignificant part building new
buildings schools got into like an arms
race about who could have the the best
cafeterias or the most
luxurious dorms or athletic facilities
and stuff like that
they pissed away lots and lots and lots
of money on that that they're never
going to get back
and that money's gone you know
that that's where a lot of the tuition
money has gone
um they've also created
vast numbers of administrators who get
paid more than faculty
and who aren't necessarily contributing
their kind of parasites as well as well
as their
their staffs sometimes it's legally
mandated but there's no reason
why people should be paid so much
another big
factor of it is the turning away from
tenure track
jobs that were paid quite well to
part-time adjunct faculty who are paid
crap for the most part
and uh visiting professor lines so i'm
going to give you an example from
marquette right
i mentioned earlier that marquette's
tuition is 43 000
a year that is less than they are paying
some of the visiting assistant
professors people who have phds
and who are teaching four classes a
semester
and don't have tenure and can never get
tenure
so that's how much they're they're
paying them
how do i know this because i actually
interviewed for a vap position and at
the end of it
the chair said so we pay this amount is
that okay with you
and i was like i was expecting a lot
more than that do you have room to
negotiate
and they said no no so the money's not
going to the professors
certainly not going to the younger
professors um
what has it got what has it been spent
on buildings
administration all sorts of other extra
[ __ ] that didn't need to happen
and because they suck themselves into
relying on low paid
labor there's not a lot of wiggle room
anymore so
student loans played a role in it but
all these other factors played a role
as well and they're probably just as
important uh in the the story that we
can tell
[Music]
um
wavy says what are your thoughts on
making language learning an integrated
part of an education system
okay so here's some good examples
language learning in singapore and india
is used to facilitate social cohesion
because of diverse demographics so if
you're talking about learning
english we already do that
most of the classes are in english right
if you're talking about learning
other languages the tendency has been to
cut that you know in the in the
early 2000s and the 1990s was like you
need to learn chinese
you know mandarin right usually but
maybe cantonese if you're if you're
doing stuff in
in hong kong you need to learn arabic
you need to learn
spanish you know these important world
languages
and and french got you know pulled along
with that as well although now there's
not that many people teaching it
there's been a turn away from that and a
closing of
foreign language departments and
programs
americans have been much more americans
were never very good at foreign
languages to begin with
and i would say they're probably worse
off now in the 2020s than they were say
in the early 2000s
as far as university goes
all right um
let's see here i'm not sure what oh okay
so nine wants to say that they're a
special exception i disagree
i have no undergraduate degree i still
studied was accepted into a graduate
degree
only doing a graduate degree as i needed
for a phd steppendum
so the only benefit of university has
been ease of study structure and
networking
well buddy that's you that's not the
majority of people
so maybe you're the you know the
unicorn um but
you don't want to try to like generalize
from that i mean if i were to generalize
from my own experience i would give
terrible advice to most people because
my my trajectory was different too you
know
um let's see yeah
duke duke says i work as a custodian at
a university construction has been
insane
yeah i mean you can see it schools where
they're like we don't have money for
this or this or this and suddenly they
put up a new dorm and you're like
well you had money for that didn't you
you know
it's kind of kind of funny you can see
where their priorities really
are eric w university should be
non-profit institutions
the majority of them are that doesn't
actually hold them back
from being uh pretty predatory
unfortunately um
let's see here all right so so we're i
think we're at the end of questions and
stuff like that
so i wanted to come back to something
that i think is raised by this
there are a lot of people who will say
why should we forgive
any student loan debt the people who
took out the loans
you know they chose to do that they knew
the risks that they were getting into
they were gambling why should we bail
them out and
my answer to that would be well okay
let's follow that logic out
we should never bail out any businesses
then because they are
often way more sketchy with what they're
doing
we shouldn't bail out any of the banks
when they
you know speculate within derivatives
and blow money and all sorts of stuff
when we have a bubble
we shouldn't do any of that as a matter
of fact we shouldn't help anybody
in in circumstances like that we should
you know
anybody who's getting something from the
government that they didn't like paid
directly into let's strip it away from
them
that's very extreme right you can see
that's that's that's not a good argument
but we could make that that sort of
argument
and so when we when we consider the
argument that's being made
these these kids knew what they were
getting into
now they want to hand out we can ask a
couple of questions did they know what
they were getting into
a lot of them didn't a lot of them were
told you have to do this
this is the way you're going to succeed
in life and then they get out and they
find out that there
there aren't a lot of jobs for them this
is a big problem by the way
not just for like humanities or arts or
stuff like that this is a huge
problem in stem this is also a huge
problem
for lawyers we had a glut of lawyers
coming out of law schools a while ago
and a lot of them couldn't find work
this is not a oh you're going off and
doing basket weaving at the university
and
having fun and all that no this affects
everybody
you know there have been a lot of people
who were sold essentially
a you know picture of the american dream
and these are the means to do it so you
need to take out debt
your your loans can change over time too
i the loans that i took out got sold to
some
some other corporation which got sold to
some other corporation
and before too long i found myself um
getting charged more for them and in
more and more honoris
circumstances and um
that's just the way it was so it's not
so simple
as you know oh they knew the risk or
something like that
and we can also think about this in
terms of
policy you know if we give incentives
like tax breaks to corporations
uh because they're going to be spending
money in the community you know
you think people aren't going to be
spending money if you
forgive some of their their student loan
debt it's a great way to actually
introduce more uh spending into the
economy that we we claim to that you
know we're all
so so you know concerned with so i think
that the
you know they knew what they were
getting into i think that's kind of a
[ __ ] argument that a lot of people
say and and there's others where they're
like listen now there's another
interesting one
i paid off my student loans nobody
helped me
why should we help these people now and
you know the answers to that could be
well it's the prudent thing to do
or it's the just thing to do since these
people were getting kind of screwed over
or your student loans were at a nice low
percent
and they weren't at eight percent like
these kids over here
or it could be why are you so worried
about
spending a bit of money on out of out of
our budget
when we spend so much money on other
stuff
to help people in ways that you weren't
helped
it's really interesting to see that this
sort of invidiousness or
envy i didn't get help so nobody else
should get help
there's a lot of people out there and
i'm one of them who are like
listen i paid off my student loans i'm
glad that i was able
to i would like other people to be
helped
and and i'm not going to say because i
did it
you know let's screw everybody else over
it reminds me of in basic training when
i was in the army
they would you know we would get treated
like crap right because that's what
basic trading is like
and there were some people like myself
who would be like man if i'm ever a
sergeant i'm not going to be such a jerk
like this sergeant is to to my troops
and then there are other people who are
like i can't wait till i get some rank
so i can
rub everybody else's face in the dirt
like this guy is doing to me
you think about the character involved
in that you know what it what it reveals
all right we got a bunch of questions
and comments popping up now
let me take some of these all right
eric says i plan on doing the same thing
for physics math no degree in applying
directly to grad school hey if that
works for you
good luck that's not what most people
are going to do
david says do you think this problem and
other similar ones like terrible care of
grad students in the u.s will give an
end to the perception of american
universities
as very prestigious
that's a great question it has not so
far
because getting grant students like free
labor
treating them all crap that's been done
for quite a while
i was amazed to find out when i started
teaching for marquette
and interacting with some of the grad
students that even though they
do ta you know teaching assistant or r.a
or teach their own classes
they didn't have their full tuition
covered they only had like a third of it
covered
the rest of it they were taking loans
out for i was like holy crap when i was
in grad school if i was like you know
ta-ing for a professor i had my tuition
covered
and even got a stipend on top of that
a lot a lot of places are being pretty
bad to their grad students
is that going to change the perception
of american universities is very
prestigious
probably not which is unfortunate
maybe we should actually evaluate stu
colleges and universities
on a kind of equity basis how do they
treat the people
you know think about this how are they
treating their students
how are they treating the people who are
teaching
very very important how are they
treating their staff the custodians
the people in food service the people
who
are secretaries or assistants those
people usually get paid
terrible wages and um
get treated like crap in academic
institutions quite frankly
we should that should be part of what
you actually see when you're like
um thinking about you know do you want
to go to this place or that place or
that place it would be kind of cool
if that if that sort of thing existed
all right uh let's see here
wavy says we're seeing a similar trend
happening in the uk lack of resources to
teach languages
failure to foster interest and state
educated students to learn languages
yeah it's i mean the uk system
unfortunately
seems to be moving in similar directions
to
whatever we've got you know because we
don't have a like a overall system
we have state systems and uh individual
universities that are overseen by
accrediting bodies that are not national
but rather are
regional but yeah there's there's some
serious issues i mean and brexit is
throwing all sorts of crazy curveballs
into the the works as well um
a lot of unforeseen well they were
foreseen by some people
but a lot of unforeseen consequences for
the the vast public
uh damn it says what do you think makes
a good student can usually make good
guesses about that regarding first-year
students
um i think being a good student means
you know
applying yourself figuring out what to
do after you screw up
and just you know keeping keeping at it
and resisting the
the urges and opportunities to cheat um
and you know can i make good guesses
about that
i wouldn't say i can but i also designed
my classes to make it difficult to
plagiarize
you know to reduce opportunities to to
do that
um duke duke says the majority of people
taking out massive student loans are
straight out of high school borderline
children being spun a narrative
i mean the mass of student loans so this
is
this is where we should think about what
um
biden was saying there is a point to
saying
listen if you went to an elite
institution
i'm not sure we should necessarily pay
for all that education for you
and those often tend to be more
expensive i mentioned university of
chicago
which is our our iv league here is 60
60 grand a year for tuition alone and
then another
17 grand on top of that for uh
room and board and 1800 for books
so that's um 80 grand a year
right there right i'm sure it costs more
to go to yale or harvard or
cornell or any any of these other places
out east
that's not where the majority of people
are going though they are going to like
you know
university of illinois at chicago rather
than university of chicago
or to places like um
lakeland or well another great example
ball state
in i used to teach for them they're a
state school it's 10 grand a year
uh for tuition and 10 grand a year for a
room and board
so 20 000 a year if you're in state
right
um you can still come out with quite a
bit of debt
ball state by the way was trying to make
itself into what they call the private
iv right they all have this aspiration
of increasing their
their stature and they're not all that
concerned with the students
unfortunately
um let's see here
kevin says forgive all debt for the poor
but not anyone
else taxpayers should not be subsidizing
the lifestyle of the doctor making
thirty thousand dollars a year
so i can agree with the last part but
where
you know who's poor and who's not all
right
screw everybody else um i mean
is are most people a doctor making 30
300 000 a year no
that's not the case um and uh taxpayers
already do subsidize medical school
in many many different ways right so
that's kind of a i think that's what
that's sort of a dead end there
um duke duke says what i'm really
curious about is if there's a direct
correlation between public
high schools and public universities if
it has to do with the plummeting funds
for classes like shop homec
zero connection because if you think
that we don't have a system
in place for you know the american
higher ed
thing there's no system as such when it
comes to high school
every single district is its own animal
as a matter of fact in indiana
where my kids went and are going
they're all school corporations you know
each one is its own thing
each state is a different thing so no
there's no
there's no correlation between those
some high schools are really well funded
some are poorly funded
you can have a really well-funded public
school
that's doing better than some private
schools and you can have
you know just block in that blocks but
you know just a few miles away from it
here like say in milwaukee
where we have some of the the worst you
know um
segregation and poverty in in the nation
for a large city
you can have schools that are in really
really rough shape
just you know down the road from a
school that's getting great
funding and stuff like that so no um
all right let's see here
john shepherd uh have many departments
at your university have been corrupted
by post-modernism post-colonialism
scholarship that's of terrible quality
no and that's just silliness you know
um he says the english language
department of my university is so full
of this garbage and i have no idea how
it got this bad well i'm sorry that
that's the case in your place but
most of the time that's that's pretty
overblown um
no that's definitely not the case at the
places that i've gone to or worked
so all right wavy it's difficult in the
uk to bounce back from a poor education
once you're past 21
too many factors prevent people from
pursuing adult education not to mention
funding cuts how is it in the usa so
that's a great question
we often
encourage people to go back to school
when
when they've lost their job right and
that's not necessarily the best time to
to channel them but we create money for
that
in many cases there's also there's
always a supply of adult learners
who want to go to school for one reason
or another
you know my mom is a great example um
now
this is 20 this is going back more than
20 years
she went to depaul when i when you know
before i was born
and paul is a private school in chicago
and she was studying french because you
know she was already a francophone so
she was going to
be a french teacher and then she met my
dad
at a party at uw madison and
they got married she dropped out and
you know he went on to you know go to
law school
and he got a cpa he was a tax attorney
and unfortunately he died when i was 11
and then my mom went back to work and
she
she worked as a secretary and um
did you know a lot of other things here
and there um
and then eventually she worked at
alverno college and she became the
secretary to the dean and she left there
because they were going to like typical
sort of austerity things were going to
make you do more with less right they're
going to have a report to a whole bunch
of people and she's like well this is bs
i'm getting out of here so she went to
marquette and she worked for marquette
university for a number of years
and she was a project secretary so she'd
get detailed to particular things and
should do a lot of organization
a lot of what she was doing was like
being a pa now she even worked for the
president
at one point and then she got out of
that and went to
tombstone pizza and became the secretary
to the general managers they went
through all this corporate
shake-up stuff and then by before she
died in 2000 she
was working in hr the entire time she
was taking classes she took classes at
alverno
because she wanted to finish her degree
and alverno had passed failed classes
they didn't have like grades or anything
like that
so when she went to marquette none of
those classes transferred so she began
again
and when she graduated it turned out or
when
she died rather it turned out that she
actually had more than enough credits to
graduate
what she'd done is change her major
several times so that she wouldn't
finish
but she so valued education that she you
know she wanted to keep doing this
you know you could you could when you
were working for marquette you could
take a class for free
each each semester and she did it and
she continued doing that when she was
working for tombstone
as a matter of fact my my mother-in-law
also
went late in life to marquette and
she graduated with honors uh several
years ago
and um you know went on to earn a
master's
so there are a lot of people who are
adults who didn't get to do it before
and they they find ways to make it
happen
that's not the case for a lot i think
it's much more about like job retraining
for for many people
so and a lot of that is dependent on the
governments that we have
is there money for it you know um
all right david says i wonder if these
high prices make it easier to graduate
in some way because otherwise it would
be outrageous
to pay ten uh ten thousand hundred
thousand dollars and not graduate
i don't think that that that it works
that way um
there are many people who um
and sometimes they they can't afford
their last semester you know
um family tragedy might happen they lose
their jobs something like that
so eric says if you don't graduate with
a degree your loan should be forgiven
i don't know that i would agree with
that um
[Music]
but we we do have so here's the thing
student loan debt
is only a good investment if it is a
good investment if you graduate
because if you don't then it doesn't do
you any good whatsoever
right so that's a that's a serious
problem
um eric says if you graduate for ivy
league you can easily repay the cost
after graduating
maybe maybe not i mean uh the ivy
leagues are
you know a whole different animal um i
had i had a mentor whose son went to
harvard
and he thought that just getting the
harvard name would like open all the
doors for him and as it turned out
you really needed to have some money
while you were at harvard so you could
do all the social activities and meet
all the right people
and then they would open the doors for
you so it's not quite so simple as you
you get there and it'll automatically
justify itself you know
the rich have ways of remaining rich you
can say
all right um
gutter ground says i've read hundreds of
textbooks and taken online college
courses from institutions of the highest
quality
philosophical testimony still not
employable
well i i don't know what to tell you
then you know
but i guess you're lucky that you got to
take uh college courses from
institutions of the highest quality so
that that's that's good
um holden says thoughts on income share
agreements as possible alternative oh
so this is an interesting question what
he's talking about there
purdue university is one of the ones and
they're predatory as hell
they're in indiana and the guy who's in
charge of it used to be the governor
and also used to be head of the prison
system when i
when i was working in it he's a slippery
guy and
these income share agreements are
instead of taking out a loan
you enter into a formal contract with
the school
that says you're going to pay back you
know a certain amount
of your income once you get out and now
there is a good side to this if you
don't make above a certain threshold
they're not going to take anything
but once you do start making money
they're going to be on your back
for good um so that's you know
that's an interesting proposal um
is that better than student loans
i don't think so i i kind of i i
think that a lot of the ways we look at
this is really
um quite bad mike says down with the
boilermakers now
you might just be from a school that's a
rival with purdue like say notre dame or
something like that but yeah the
boilermakers are purdue right
um eric says the view of university
studies as work preparation programs
will make niche subjects suffer in
funding
universities will stray from true
learning and creativity when governed by
boring market forces well that has been
the case for the last 40 years
um as a matter of fact that that's been
a problem in the past i mean
uh look at cs lewis's that hideous
strength for a nice parody
of that sort of thing happening way back
in his time
in in fiction this is this is this is a
a
a genuine issue um there are a lot of
programs that are being
closed because they're viewed as what
they call
low performing they're not putting out
as many majors
and they're they're teaching things that
are valuable to study
but they're not they're not big draws
now that said i'll say
this you know if you want to keep a
philosophy program
active you have to find ways to get
people to major in philosophy
and so you can't just keep doing as many
of my colleagues do the same old song
and dance
you better figure out some way to make
the philosophy club
really active to figure out you know
pipelines for you know if you're going
to do philosophy
how do you move this into other fields
you're going to have to bring in people
who have philosophy degrees and are
working in other places
you're gonna have to find ways to
essentially you know
affect what we call placement um and
i've known some people who are quite
good at that and most of my colleagues
are terrible at it and uninterested in
it
and then they're surprised when people
are like your head's on the chopping
block
you you do have to justify your
existence there are a lot of creative
ways that you can justify your existence
and make a career out of doing you know
things with philosophy
um leila says gainful employment rules
what do you think of them i'm not quite
sure what's being referred to as gainful
employment rules
so i can't can't really say that an
answer to that
um gutter ground says market forces are
the product of market power
porter forces i'm not sure what that
means
uh the x
something what's your opinion on the
recent university of manchester rent
strike by refusing to pay rent students
managed to reduce what they had to pay
for accommodation
in protest of pervasive marketization
well if you can if you can do that
i guess that's that's quite good um
[Music]
you know that's that would be like in a
lot of our states here in the united
states
that would probably be illegal to do
because we've got so many laws on the
books that so
favor um the you know the
not renters but the the rentiers the
people who are renting
to others and yeah that'd be that'd be
tough to do um
okay so leela says if you can't get a
job with your degree your loans get
forgiven
um what do i what do i think of that um
i mean
i think that you know we probably
should do better in counseling people
about where the jobs are likely to be
there's a lot of people who get stem
degrees and then find out that what they
train for
doesn't exist anymore or isn't going to
pay what they thought it was going to
pay
[Music]
i don't know that we should
automatically you know forgive all of
their loans for that
especially if they're they were like
well i'm not going to do any of these
other things because i know stem is
where it's at
or getting a business degree for example
or a psychology degree or something like
that
all right um
let's see here
well somebody's quoting thomas sowell
yeah i i quit reading him years and
years and years ago after having
his books recommended to me and reading
him and being like ugh
you know so all right um
joe any philosophy departments in europe
any better funded
it really depends on the country right
um yeah some of them are way better
funded
but um it depends on what you know so
so universities in europe for the most
part
are not just as we call them state
institutions but they're part of the
country as a state right rather than
being
state as in like the state of wisconsin
or state of illinois
or things like that they're more like
what what our federal government would
be doing and our federal government
really doesn't run many
colleges or universities um
philosophy can be prioritized
in in much better ways it usually you
know the smart way to do that is to show
that it's connected don't just do
philosophy for its own sake right
show that philosophy can actually say
something productive to
business people or help psychology
people learn some of their own past
you know where they came from and not
not just be doing the latest uh
discourse and experiments or um do you
know
helping us understand technological
development or things like that
philosophy really does have to justify
itself i think
all right
let's see here
ps says we should be creating great
trade schools for things like
engineering
most of what you need to know for your
job is taught to you by your business
colleges should be for students who want
to work closely under masters of their
fields most college university students
don't care about learning because they
just want a job
i would never generalize about most
college university students because we
don't really know i mean how many of
them
have you talked to um you can say most
of the ones i've
i've met or taught right um
we should be creating great trade
schools for things
not like engineering engineering already
has schools they're called engineering
schools marquette has one
right down the road uh we should be
creating great trade schools for all
sorts of other things and we should
you know make it so that trade schools
aren't looked down upon as like oh well
if you're stupid that's where you go you
know which is unfortunately what we do
here in the united states
um so yeah i think i think there's
something to be said for that
a college's unit should be for students
who want to work closely under masters
of their fields
okay yeah that's that's a great idea um
if you can get them to to accept that i
mean my ad
milwaukee institute of art and design
one of the places i teach for they do do
that
right i mean it's it's a professional
school i love teaching there actually
because they're still
so student-centered and they're so
supportive of the faculty
they brought me in to be you know
somebody to teach classes in the
humanities
specifically in philosophy so
all right um
let's see here
oh here's a great question by griffin
how are you eu countries
like germany able to provide free
university of education do you think
this would be possible in the us
it'd be totally possible in the us i
mean there's a few things we'd have to
do
first we'd have to tell all the colleges
you're going to get
this much and that's what we'll pay for
and you're not getting anything above
that so harvard you know you've got a
great
uh um endowment you ought to be taking
care of your people anyway you get
nothing
um marquette university you
are going to get 20 grand per student
the rest of the money that you you're
pissing away on [ __ ] projects
you not you need to knock that off by
the way you've also got a
700 million endowment so you got money
in the bank and you own real estate
around town
find a way to to you know provide your
students university of wisconsin-madison
and milwaukee and ball state university
and university of
illinois at chicago we'll pay for you
you know
use state schools we could easily do
that all we'd have to do is shift
priorities a bit
and um you know make sure that the
things are done in a sort of standard
way
if you look at the amount of money that
we piss away
as a nation on
military stuff it's mind-boggling
trillions and trillions of dollars not
just spent
but unaccounted for
we have 1.5 trillion dollars in student
loan debt
how much did we spend on bailouts
for kovit when we when we want to give
ppe loans
we can come up with the money right some
of our legislators
even you know got got at the pig at the
trough on that
when it comes to education if we really
valued education
we could do it easily as a country you
know there's all sorts of things like
that if we want to have a good health
care system if we wanted to have
national health care
we could do that you know we'd have to
spend less money on other things
it's all a matter of priorities you know
it's not a
uh impossibility whenever somebody says
where's the money coming
going to come from and we say where the
hell is the money coming from for all
these
you know uh bases we have overseas or
all of these corporate handouts or all
these other things you've got the money
for that don't you
so don't ask where where the money's
going to come from those people who are
the critics of that
all right gutter grown wants to say 85
percent of revenue goes to large
corporations most people are employed by
small businesses the fact that 40
of workers make less than 15 ph
evidence that everyone can't succeed
okay yeah i i guess so i'm not sure what
the last part
means but yeah there's the large
corporations are way
better at bogarting they're part of
the money that gets spent right and they
you know they hire huge lobbyists and
they they can afford you know uh very
expensive legal teams that prevent
challenges so
yeah there's a lot of a lot of things
like that going on
so um yeah
let's see here
[Music]
oh 15 per hour that's that's what you're
saying
it's it's it's interesting to see all
these um
complaints you know the 15 per hour as a
fair minimum wage that would have been
several years ago
if if minimum wage had been indexed to
uh inflation and
it's kind of funny so one of the people
in another town hall
said to biden that he was a um
he owned a manufacturing company in
milwaukee
and he was like you know if things go up
to 15 an hour
i'm not going to be able to pay that to
my workers and
i was like you know if he was living way
out in the sticks
you know that would kind of make sense
to say oh you know my my prices are
going to go too high
but you're in milwaukee if you're paying
somebody less than 15
an hour to live here in milwaukee and
work for you you are paying them poverty
wages
you know so these people who come you
know say oh everything's gonna cost so
much more
it's not what the you know experiments
actually show
and it's usually very self-serving kind
of kind of you know rhetoric
on their part uh real game machine says
we need to try to harness the free
market better by aiming it towards
things that would be more beneficial for
everyone
fusion tech yeah i mean the way that you
harness the free market better
ironically is by regulating it um you
know
there's there's there's everyone's like
either like
against regulation altogether in red
tape or they're for it
and they forget that we should be saying
is this good regulation or bad
regulation
you know we should we should consider it
case by case
so much of the deregulation that we've
done um
has really opened the door for predatory
practices
and we probably need to have a new
regime of regulation and people aren't
going to like that because they never
like it when you're
you know cutting into the money that
they're making or
the power that they have but that that's
what we need to do if we want to have a
more
rational functional capitalist economy
and if we don't do it we're screwed i
mean america
is in many respects by certain measures
sort of a
failing nation and
we we are at the point where we could
turn some of this around but we really
need to do it soon if we're going to do
it let's come back to the the education
and student loans thing so how would how
would that figure
into this again i want to say that
paying off some measure of people's
student loans would put you know
more spending power uh for
important products cars houses
you know further education in the hands
of people who would be
spending that money and it circulates
within the economy
so that would be good to do uh
j robital regulation always leads to
special pleading even among its most
avoid acolytes
no if you're gonna if you're gonna say
always about any human affair thing
you're already off the you know off the
beaten path
uh gutter ground is here any player
large enough to affect market prices is
stopping the free market actualization
yeah
this is what we call an externality
right or not an externality a market
failure rather
um whenever we get oligopolies or
monopolies or cartels
um this is not capitalism the way it's
supposed to actually work you know and
the only way to do anything about it
is you know use the the force of the
government
so um
david country chick says all of my
education trade degree associate degree
and bachelor were substantially lacking
zero quality provided i'm sure that's
not true that zero quality was provided
because if it was and you were a
rational agent you would have gotten out
of there right at the start right
so you must have gotten something out of
it it may not have been up to
the standards of what you wanted maybe
one of the things that we need to do is
to make it easier to move from
institution to institution if you think
you're not getting what you want
that's probably important and i will say
there are a lot of crappy professors and
a lot of crappy programs out there
um so that's that's you know um well
worth taking into account
alberto says i think something that
would help student debts if schools were
honest about cost of attendance it's not
just tuition
well like like we were saying before
they are honest about that they say
i mean when my daughter was going to uwm
they gave us a whole
sheet that says like this costs this and
this costs this this costs this
and then she's in musical theater so
there's other fees for things
so they they do do that um yeah there's
all these weird fees that are hundreds
of dollars
um yeah so you you
you know in some programs you can
actually know what they are
i mean uh my daughter had to have
um like you know because one of the
classes
there's an accompaniment companies you
pay for that
you pay for your material fees and
things like that
books are prohibitively expensive that
is a big problem
um some of the you know i might i always
like talk to my college students
before class starts and i ask them like
hey how much are your books for this
class or that class we kind of
shoot the breeze as they say some of the
textbooks are 200 300
it's it's crazy what they they have to
pay
so again on my part i try to make it as
cheap for them as possible
real g machine if if universities could
have incentives placed on them to ensure
students are more likely to get good
jobs
that would solve some of our problems
yeah that that would be interesting how
how would you
work that
[Music]
you would have to find some way to like
follow all these students and see
what they're actually getting five years
ten years
out there and the trouble is you're
rewarding them
in the present for what students have
been doing
in in the past i don't know i don't know
that that would be that much of a
incentive um here's actually a good an
interesting question
and it's not about student loan debt and
i've got a off the wall answer to this
joe smith what are the top five
universities for philosophy
there are no top five universities for
philosophy and anybody who creates a
ranking system is full of crap
because there's no way to measure
who would be the best at doing
philosophy
or history or so many other things
there are so many factors that go into
it
you can get a great education at a place
that hasn't made it very high
in brian leiter's philosophical gourmet
which which a lot of people are still
stupid enough to read
and use um it was it was kind of a
laughing stock
even when i was in it because obviously
it's going to wind up being the people
who have the kind of programs he likes
that that you know
do well um and you have to consider is
there any real objectivity here
how does even gather information right
there are no top
you have to look at it as what's going
to be the best for you
if you're like going into a philosophy
program you want to know who all those
faculty are and if they're people that
you can work
work with and learn from you could go to
a place that has super prestigious
people like university of chicago and it
could do
nothing for you right so that's a really
good thing to keep in mind
um zach
asks what makes university so expensive
yeah so we talked about this a little
bit before tuition costs have gone up
massively because universities
pissed away money on buildings and on
creating administrative positions with
their own
staff and they got themselves hooked on
using adjunct labor rather than
actually having tenure-track professors
and they spend money on all sorts of
other stupid things as well i mean
universities
for the most part no more than most
businesses most
most businesses you look at their their
what they're spending their money on
it's not well run it's kind of a dirty
little secret
business people aren't any smarter than
anybody else
there are some businesses that are
really well run and then there's a lot
of businesses
where you're like what's this expense
for how is this giving us a return on
investment
universities when they are run like
businesses they run as badly as
businesses do
so that that's part of it i call almost
the best education
as the friends we made along the way uh
that's that's that's
yeah i mean that's that's part of what
happens when you when you study i
suppose right
oh here's a good question from griffin
is the money from textbooks going to the
scholars who write them or the
publishers
the vast majority of the money unless
it's self-published
is going to the publishers so i have a
book that was
originally intended to be like a
textbook
kind of a niche thing right with an
academic press
and i think on every book that's sold
now
after a certain point i make 2.5
royalties right
the rest of it goes all to the press 97
if you self-publish with amazon um if
you're in their sweet spot you get 70
of the take otherwise you get 30 of the
take which is still
30 compared to two and a half percent
way better
right so if i if i write a textbook i'd
self-publish it on amazon
you know um yeah the majority of the
money that you're paying
for college four books is not going to
the authors
the majority of the money that you're
paying intuition
is not going to the professors it's
going to all these other things as well
you know all right a universalist it
seems like things like art or humanities
degree don't produce as market value as
stem field but they have value to
society
that market doesn't account for what do
you think on this matter
stem degrees don't provide that much
value either i mean
look at what people actually make when
they graduate with a degree in the hard
sciences and how
hard it is for them to find gainful
employment you know
most people don't get to work on their
own projects they work on something
for somebody else there's a glut on some
things mathematicians don't make a hell
of a lot of money and that's the m
in in stem right so
you know they're the same thing with
business people can graduate the
business degree and not be able to find
a job
you know um
jay roberts isle says i've never seen
one civilian one civilian that supports
more regulation without picking and
choosing regulations that they like and
they don't
the one counter example i might count is
the government itself
yeah that's why we have politics i mean
this is this is not so what
does that make it like well we shouldn't
have regulation for that reason
um all right eric says do you think
professors will keep
writing textbooks even with no economic
incentives
at all for putting them online for free
i mean like i was just saying if you
self-published with amazon you could get
30 of the take
or even 70 of the take that's not a no
economic
incentive most textbooks are are
actually crap so i've actually thought
of writing a few textbooks myself where
i'm like
none of the ones that i have are very
good i could write a better textbook
than this
i just don't i don't have the time right
um but
you know i know what what the students
are having trouble with and what they
need to know more of and
i think there's plenty of economic
incentive and there's there's other
people who will write textbooks because
they like writing textbooks and they
they enjoy that sort of thing
yeah kolomov says i hear i thought all
the monies people spent on works by kant
went to khan well that's an interesting
one that
like it's going to the press itself
because all
well i mean so if it's a translation
a new translation it's going to the
translator an editor
right so you see these cambridge or
or um you know oxford university press
books where there's like a new edition
of say cicero
by pick whoever
you like martha nussbaum martha nussbaum
is getting part of the cut
right so um
let's see here oh this is a good
question um
by joshua what do you think about less
than legal means of accessing academic
materials for free
like scihub library genesis z library
i should mention just to be you know um
comprehensive in this that you know you
can find a lot of things for free on
academia.edu
you can also find a lot of philosophy
stuff on phil papers
people upload their things there uh what
do i think about it i think that the
publishers
the publishers have been screwing over
the public
professors and researchers for years and
years and years deriving huge profits
and that they don't deserve and if if
you know i'll start
worrying about um those less-than-legal
means of accessing academic material
i'll start considering that a real
problem uh when i see an equitable
distribution
on the part of the publishers like you
know elsevier um
until that i don't really care you know
it's a non-issue for me
so um and i think that we should there's
a lot of things where we ought to do
this where we ought to say
i'm not going to worry about this
particular thing over here until
this thing over here that's a much more
egregious problem
gets addressed if you're not talking
about this i don't want to hear about
this
i'll give you an example from another
format when i hear
you know people who call themselves
christians talking about leviticus and
homosexuality i'm always like
how are you doing with the sermon on the
mount you know the stuff in the gospels
that you about the guy you claim to
actually be centering your life on
how are you doing with that if you're
not doing anything with that then you
know
shut up about you know what i almost
said there shut up about this stuff over
here
because and i feel that way about sort
of the academic publishers
they are doing stuff that's so
egregiously
wrong um that i don't i don't really
care what happens to them frankly
you know um
let's see here
yeah so cola moose brings up a very good
point about academia.edu
academia.edu is also a predatory place
the problem with them is once you get on
there they send you non-stop
emails and a lot of it's kind of a waste
of your time they've found ways to
monetize
what they're doing um all right so i'm
gonna go out on this
this question from universal set because
we're at
time now what do i think about
professors who are obviously very smart
but don't know how to teach very well
so if they are like brand new like out
of grad school
then i think you know you work with them
you coach them you tell them hey you
need to learn how to teach better
and if they come back with you at you
and they're like i don't give a [ __ ]
about teaching
well then maybe they shouldn't be in
teaching positions and if that's the
case they also shouldn't be in research
positions you know
we earn by by teaching that teaching
should be the absolute basis
everybody should be teaching by the way
somebody who i admire very greatly
aleister mcintyre
could have just taught graduate level
classes deliberately while he was at
notre dame taught undergraduate classes
he said i'm not going to be like anybody
else and i think that this
really matters you know he walked the
walk of virtue ethics
i think if it's somebody who's been in
position for a while and they
they're not a good teacher maybe we need
to replace them with somebody who is
you know there's there's nothing to say
that just because somebody can write
a lot of books that they they deserve an
academic post
you know academic pulse should be
primarily oriented around teaching
and i think everybody should teach
service classes
you know intro to philosophy ethics
those sort of things there's a sadler uh
soapbox video specifically about that
so i think that um
you know there are like things you can
learn that would make you a better
teacher
and i think that teachers have a moral
responsibility
as well as a fiduciary responsibility in
some respects as well
you know sort of attenuated uh to their
their institution to improve their
teaching
unfortunately most institutions don't
really seem to care about that
or if they they do care about it they
you know they don't use sufficient means
to to make it better so on that i
am going to um bring this to a close
talked about a lot of different things i
would suggest you go
and check out the the town hall that
biden did
here in milwaukee uh look at the
proposals that he put out which i think
largely are you know on point um
and you know there's some some problems
that i pointed out earlier like the
pretending that
private schools are all ivy league
obviously that's
that's not the case um but you know it's
it's uh well worth checking out
and uh those of you who are trapped in
in debt let me
say that you you definitely have my
sympathy i know many people and i've
known many people going back
to my undergraduate who carried great
student loans
and it has a massive impact on them
this is something we're going to have to
figure out how to do something about
if if we want a better society here in
the united states so
all right i'll see all of you